my friend Roseanne Bar was on Bill Mah's
podcast uh talking about another way
it's not just through censorship it's
not just through big Tech it's also that
they will come for your jokes she made
one off-hand joke and they canceled her
you tweeted something that I don't even
know if you thought it was racist it
certainly was it was not well okay well
I thought the was why I know that's what
you thought you're not going to get
yourself out of this by by reiterating
you if you can't take a joke you
you fascist that's how I feel Bill and
you know what I don't give a what color
your ass is if you ain't doing right for
your own people or anybody's people in
this country where people are sleeping
in the streets and it makes me
sick then you I don't give a
about your feelings you are offensive to
me